look at this fine fine house on a
beautiful spring day here in New York
City welcome to the world science
festival it's so great what the World
Science Vessel intern if you realize is
actually an elegant proof of quantum
mechanics because for the four days of
the festival both brian greene and tracy
day are in six places at once and we
love that about this festival it's great
to be here i mean i love this venue the
Cooper Union
I mean filled with old socialists I mean
come on this is a fabulous place here
arguing about this and that I mean
imagine all the scientists that we could
pack into this room having an argument
you mean there to be the Pope over there
and there'd be you know Rutherford over
here and and maybe you know Letterman
over here and not David and the Pope
would be saying though the world began
4004 BC and over here they'd say oh but
it was a big bang yes it was a big bang
in 4000 BC and people would be shouting
and screaming let's try to simulate that
if we could because this is a great hall
of the abolitionist movement I mean
there were spirited passionate debates
here over here you say the earth is flat
it's obvious everybody
that's ridiculous the earth is round
now mix it up
that's the idea that's the spirit that's
the spirit science and story is our
mission and what is science but the
story of our understanding of the world
the story of civilization on some level
the story of great discoveries and so
science and literature merge and do I
have a great job or what I mean Brian
mention that you know I have this radio
show the takeaway and and what that show
allows me to do I've been doing radio
and TV for years as a journalist I mean
what you get to do as a journalist it's
something I'm sure some of you know this
it's called strand bingeing any of you
strand of injures here for those of you
are out of town The Strand of course is
a spectacular bookstore here in the city
of New York and they're selling books
actually outside tonight and you're
welcome to purchase any of the books
that may hit your fancy tonight but
strand binging is you get a big bag like
this empty and you go to the Strand or
you can go to any bookstore any
independent bookstore or barnes and
noble even it's totally fine you can
pinch at Barnes and Noble
so alliteration works there Barnes &
Noble binging you know that works I
liked the first strand binging you gonna
just pick out just a bunch of stuff just
you know I mean let me tell you what I
got I hear any strand ventures in the
audience by the way you go and just by
way too many books yeah right alright so
um Steven Pinker's the better angels of
our nature words coined by Abraham
Lincoln and once spoke here right right
it's all about apparently it's all about
like violence has declined in the world
and I guess if you're a tenured
professor at Harvard you can be
optimistic about our civilization so
then then oh man Joyce Carol Oates
Carthage is her latest here and I better
finish this because her next book is
coming out in about an hour
yeah and and then here's here's some
interesting here's some interesting
stuff the the particle at the end of the
universe it's about the the Higgs boson
any fans of the Higgs boson here yeah I
have all their albums they're outrageous
they're fantastic anyway this is great
this is a real immersion into physics
it's all about the it's all about the
the super collider and the discovery of
the Higgs boson or what may be the
discovery of the Higgs boson chrétien
have that argument you over on this side
say we've discovered the Higgs boson you
say no no we may have discovered the
Higgs boson right over here over here
and you say yeah see that is actually
what's going on in physics right now and
that we've done it right here in this
room and what else that I thought oh
this is great this is really great this
book by Jo Marchand the shadow king it's
all about how the early Egyptologists
who got who got to the King Tut's body
out of the tomb
essentially ransacked it like a bunch of
you know thieves knocking over a
7-eleven on a Saturday night and they
actually did autopsies on the mummy
which have about as much sophistication
as a you know a teenager dissecting a
frog you know as part of their like
science project and it's it's really
interesting how the science of
Egyptology and archaeology has changed
over time and I'm very very interested
in this and then this one here it's
another book by by Joe and decoding the
heavens about ancient Greeks and the
development of a astronomical computer
2,000 years ago I knew nothing about
this nothing about this and then you
know you always when you go strand
bingeing right
its history nonfiction political strange
strange strange weird something you'll
never read something you might read and
then you got it you got to do a classic
right doctor oh I mean hello Andrews
brain and this seems great to me I read
a little bit of it and
and a total stretch for him I mean this
is about as far from ragtime as anything
he's ever written and you know I I don't
know how often you go strand binging but
I do it enough so that sometimes I
actually actually dream about it at
night and at one time I had this had
this dream that I was you know strand
binging I grabbed a bunch of books and
sat in the park you know I was just
sitting there cracking open the books
looking at them you know and then
something happened in my dream as I was
sitting there in this park suddenly the
authors of the books that I binge
started to appear in the park they sort
of walked over and sat next to me he's
legendary authors I mean I was just
crazy or what I mean they walked over
they sat down it was like that scene in
Woody Allen's Annie Hall right when
Marshall McLuhan comes up to Woody Allen
and they actually talk about an argument
and suddenly I'm surrounded by these
books and here are these authors people
who I'm really curious about legendary
authors
I mean it's astounding
of course that would never happen anyway
welcome to to the right angle science
and story thanks for being here and
thanks for indulging my little stick
here it's great to have you and just for
those of you who are playing at home
Sean Carroll il doctor Oh Joe Marchand
Joyce Carol Oates and Steven Pinker and
let's just say do you have any idea why
we picked the five of you yes I know why
you picked them right that's yeah all of
you know why the others were picked it's
it's why you were here they all quite
understand well part of the mix here is
in the case of you Sean and you Joe you
are scientists doctorate in genetics
don't try to pass yourself off as a
geneticist here and you are a doctrine
in physics that's right right
but you embraced write it for a lay
audience you still do scientific papers
absolutely yeah yeah yeah you're forced
scientists right at Harvard it's
psychology right it's that close yes
right and why did the three of you go
from scientific rigorous research to
writing did you want to put on a
different hat Stephen what I was doing
was too interesting to keep to myself in
my colleagues the world was interested
in how the mind works and how language
works and I thought it's a part of my
responsibility as
a scientist and its professor to share
it the taxpayers pay for the research
they have a right to the insights of the
fascinating discoveries that we make so
I thought it was part of my
responsibility that's a sign to crazy
virtuous whoa Joe how about you okay I
don't think I have the patience or the
determination to be a scientist but as a
journalist every week I get to talk to
somebody who spent their entire career
getting to an amazing exciting you know
breakthrough point and then I get to
talk to them about it so you know it'll
be a different field every time and then
I get that access I get to share in that
and then I get to write about it and at
Caltech
you of course it's the taxpayers they're
paying for your research and yeah well
Steve already took my virtuous response
so I'll admit that it's just fun I you
know it's fun to write it's fun to share
this excitement but also when you're
doing science you're always at the edge
of the stuff we don't understand and
you're struggling and you don't know
what's going on and then we do know
what's going on you move on to the next
thing but in the writing you get to sort
of linger and cherish those moments when
you figure something out in the case of
you Edgar and you Joyce you are of
course writers but is there something
about science that intrigues you either
in terms of a character or a domain of
content certainly you spend a lot of
time talking about what goes on in the
brain in your latest book yes but the
difference I think here is that the
scientists professional scientists
whatever field find an intrinsic value
in science whereas we fiction writers
see it as an extrinsic value that is to
say
we what we take what we can use from it
for our own purposes
so if you need to you ripoff scientists
you need to rip off cops you rip off
cops right it's it's really a lower form
of exploitation yes
again another virtuous response Joyce
how would you respond to the
intersection of science and your work as
a novelist and storyteller well both
Edgar and I are really chroniclers of
American history in American culture
just American life and science is part
of that but I think the most exciting
feature of science in the nineteenth
century let's say is the is the
discovery of evolution or evolutionary
theory and it's really the intersection
with culture with religion so if you're
interested in American culture and
religion and you know popular life in
America the incursion of Darwinian
evolutionary theory until then is very
natural so in writing about one year you
would inevitably be writing about the
other and I mean so much of the American
story and I guess the global story of
modernity is about the encounter of
populations with the implications of
scientific discovery that's
philosophical in the case of Darwin but
there's also the story of electricity
and how it changed cities and there's
some great books Erik Larsson wrote a
great book about how lighting in the
cities change Chicago and he wrote a
whole big murder mystery around it
it's really really an amazing story
that's all about American history would
you say that you ever wanted to be a
scientist
Edgar yeah well no I see I went to the
Bronx High School of Science I I know
and I found myself hanging out with kids
who are going around predicting in some
cases correctly that they were going to
win the Nobel Prize in physical so that
immediately drove me to the office where
the literary magazine was and there my
future was made there right
what novelists do you particularly like
Sean there's a lot of novelists the ones
with some science in them I you know I
would say people like Thomas Pynchon
you had to say Tom Stoppard playwright
not a novelist but I like the people who
can use science without making it too
much like a lecture I've had enough
lectures in my life I get those very
easily when I go to read a novel or
watch a play or see a movie or TV show I
want to be entertained and provoked and
if there is a scientific angle there if
they're able to make use of science in
some provocative way then that's really
great Joe is your work in some sense a
memoir of your discovery of these
various stories and interesting scenes
and sort of subcultures in the case of
Egyptology and the Greek archaeologists
and sponge divers that you write so
beautifully about it I guess the shadow
king was more that than decoding the
heavens so the shadow king was very much
a personal journey I kind of went out to
talk to these people and reconstruct
this story because Egyptology is such a
a show you know we get these really big
budget National Geographic and discovery
documentaries and these headlines
scientific findings and everything is
you know all the science that's done is
paid for by TV companies and you know
everything's very toothy at Racal so I
just wanted to go behind the scenes
what's it really like in the basement of
the Egyptian Museum or in Tutankhamun's
tomb or where the archives held or who
are these people who would you know who
is the geneticist that took the DNA from
Tut's mummy and why do these people even
want to do this work what's driving them
I suppose I was much more interested in
those people and their stories than in
the actual scientific results Stephen
you have an editor right
oh yes this is your editor a tenured
professor at Harvard no no is she a
psychologist no Wendy Woolf is she have
a doctorate yeah
she she does not but she is a brilliant
editor really and she can tell you to
write that paragraph thing oh she does
not micromanage but she will say this
doesn't make any sense or I'm not
following you and then leaves it to me
to fix the problem and that's the kind
of editor I like to work with the best
so in fact the exact opposite of your
students at Harvard I also have a I've
worked with a copy editor for most of my
books from whom I've learned a lot about
both the mechanics of punctuation and
capitalization but also coherence and
clarity and consistency katya rice I've
worked with for more than 30 years at
one point I had to work with a different
copy editor for one of my writings and I
was so disgruntled that I decided to
write my own style manual too because I
thought that this confident girl was
miss educated on rules of grammar and so
I had to write my own book so they know
that's that's the kind of terror that
you would inspire and editors sometimes
sean is the mission when you're writing
a book from your editors perspective
that hey if I don't get it man no one
else will so it's gotta work for me or
do you want to a little familiar there
baby or are you trying to sort of dump
the people into the real sort of debate
as it happens the language as the
scientists use it in the moments that
they're experiencing the discoveries I
think my editor is all too willing to
let things go that make no sense to him
whatsoever so maybe more of that would
be helpful but I think that the boring
answer here but it's a little bit of
both the first book from eternity to
here that I wrote was much more about
bringing people right to the
mind-bending ideas at the forefront of
research even if some of those ideas
from the 19th century it's still stuff
that we're not familiar with in our
everyday lives the higgs-boson book is
much more about telling a ripping yarn
and getting people caught up in the
process of discovering this wonderful
thing but even there you know I can't
help but have a couple of chapters that
really say okay now you've had your fun
and we're going to eat some vegetables
here and we're gonna think about why
forces of nature arise because of
symmetries that independently hold at
every point in space-time so have you
ever channeled some of your writing
about boxing is some of the best writing
about boxing that I've ever ever read
I'm such an admirer of your work but it
seems like one of the talents that you
have choices to be able to inhabit a
character that to both the reader and I
suspect to you on some level is remote
and yet you go there and inhabit that
character it's some of the mission of
science writing in the sense that
scientists are by definition in some
cases remote from all of us how do you
do that what what do you what do you
what is exciting to you about that well
it's an interesting question which I
think writers are wrong often ask but I
don't think there's anything mystical
were mysterious about it I don't have a
conception of being an artist or poet of
the kindness that Plato had this is a
demonic channeling and that the
conscious mind is not really aware of
what's going on I don't have that's not
really my my feeling about literature at
all literature is a text that's it's a
it's a creation of language and the
Texas and it's it has a structure
sentences have a certain coherence or
rhythm you can choose if they weren't
short sentences longer sentence or a
mixture you choose the will you choose
the way that the page looks you know
there's a good deal that's very
conscious and the pacing and the
movement of writing has something in
common maybe with with music you know
these things that are very much of the
conscious mind but the main thing about
writing and storytelling is that one
feels one has an exciting and original
story to tell that has some surprises
and so whether you're reading fiction or
nonfiction or memoir you basically are
starting out at a certain point and then
you are going to be a little surprised
yourself by what what develops and
that's the great excitement and the
thrill of writing and also reading Edgar
how was your research for the book Water
Works which I think involved probably a
certain amount of engineering if not
science and your research for this
latest book on the brain to understand
some of the things that you write about
with such fluency you're asking how much
research I do of course it was
voluminous I know
oh my answer is just enough but it's
interesting that you mentioned the
waterworks briefly for the most of you
who haven't read that book it takes
place in the New York City during the
boss tweed era and a young man sees a
coach going by on the street with a
bunch of old men including his father
except that his father has died as is he
understands it and he's so possessed by
this image and traumatized that he gets
a friend of his to help him enter the
body and they go up to Woodlawn Cemetery
and pry up the pry open the coffin and
his father isn't in the coffin a child
is in the coffin and it turns out that
this doctor Sartorius reads Sartorius is
keeping old men alive in this place
using the materials as the blood of
children who usually do not survive his
treatment so did you see something that
came out in the New York Times about two
weeks ago about how researchers
discovered
that if they inject old mice with the
blood of young mice
the old mice revived a friend of mine
who's a scientist smart Nemer said I
deserve the Nobel Prize in medicine I
was gonna say yeah you should get your
application in but it's real it's really
weird but it it just shows you that
there's there's some endowment that
comes with making things up
a part of the story of science and Edgar
refers to it there a little bit is the
ways in which scientific discoveries
particularly really abstract scientific
discoveries are internalized by the
population it seemed for most of the
20th century and I didn't live for most
in the 20th century but I was born
mid-century that the idea of relativity
was very remote and and incomprehensible
to most Americans and that people had an
intuitive sense of Newtonian mechanics
and of course if you read the story of
Isaac Newton and what he talked about in
gravity and all of that it seemed as
though people grasped Newton much more
quickly although it actually did take a
few hundred years compared with what
they thought was going on before that
versus relativity which I thought oh
well we'll just understand what
relativity is and and it didn't it
didn't really occur to me that we were
internalizing relativity until movies
like The Matrix began to play with this
sort of time-travel business and then
all of a sudden it seems in the last
2025 years that some aspects of
relativity have been internalized and
become part of popular culture how do
you observe that phenomenon as a
scientist and where do you think the
Higgs boson is gonna end up in popular
culture I think that phenomenon would be
awesome if it were true I'm not sure
that even undergraduates have quite
internalized relativity yet and quantum
mechanics is quite a ways off I mean
immediately after this I'm racing down
to do another World Science Festival
event where a bunch of us professors are
going to argue
what quantum mechanics means because the
theory has been there for most of the
20th century and we still don't
understand it yet
well the argument sound like what's the
Arrogant what's that argument sound like
oh it's the are technically as you could
probably say it don't try to dumb us
down okay all right no okay the
wavefunction is an element of hilbert
space no that's ridiculous
yes I think you know to go back to your
question the the we think that Newtonian
mechanics seems intuitive to us it isn't
I mean Newtonian mechanics says that if
you don't exert a force on something it
keeps moving at a constant velocity
forever Aristotelian mechanics says that
in order to keep something moving yet to
keep pushing it and that is very
intuitive to us because it's true in the
real world you have to keep pushing
something and there's this great leap
that Galileo and Newton made that says
let's ignore friction and air resistance
and they invented physics and much of
modern science by doing that but
Newtonian mechanics is closer to our
intuition relativity is further than
that quantum mechanics is even further
than that in quantum mechanics the rules
that we give people in textbooks say
that there's one kind of thing that
happens when you're looking at something
and another kind of thing that happens
when you're not looking at it and we
don't like that and we no one really
thinks that's true and yet we teach it
to every second year physics student
that comes along so we're trying to do
better than that and this is the least
surprising thing in the world as science
gets better and better at understanding
the world in a more more quantitative
full complete way of course it's going
to be completely different than our
intuition which is trained by a very
limited realm of experience right we
don't see things every day that move
close to the speed of light we don't see
things that are the size of an electron
and responds to you every day that move
at the speed of light we I'm I know yeah
I hesitated when I was saying rats and
yeah I saw the trap come down okay we're
in the right Hall to screw around like
that John and this is any of
philosophers know this well this is
Willard cellars talked about the
manifest image the image that we all
have in our in our minds about what's
happening the world and the scientific
image and he said the job of philosophy
was to reconcile these and the struggles
of a physicist to do this are nothing
compared to the struggles of a
neuroscientist to do this right I mean
the way that we think about thinking is
as wrong compared to how thinking
actually happens as the way we think
about matter is different than the rules
of a lot of makes let's put that to mr.
Pinker here how is our intuition about
the brain in a state of real flux right
now and what does that mean for you as a
writer
well it'd be the most intuitive theory
of how the mind works is that it is
inhabited by an immaterial substance
like the soul there there's an eye that
uses the brain the way we might use a
smartphone and it's very hard to get
used to the idea that we don't use our
brain we are our brain that there isn't
some animating essence that that pulls
the levers of behavior and that reads
the screens but it's just neurons all
the way down I think that is the the
fundamental mismatch between the view of
the mind given to us by neuroscience and
the intuitive way of thinking of the
mind that's analogous to the difficulty
of grasping relativity and quantum
mechanics so the AI is the letter I
guess I is the camera on the smartphone
that's right so which is why it's so
easy for us to attribute minds to things
that don't have minds like to human-made
objects so you have idolatry to
mountains and rivers and trees so you
have animism to nothing in particular so
you've got ghosts and spirits and souls
we're so used to attributing a kind of
invisible essence or agency to other
people when we deal with them we don't
deal with other people as brains we deal
with them as people that it and we
abstract some kind of immaterial force
which we can then attribute to objects
or natural things or nothing in
particular and that's where you get
spiritualism and a lot of religious
beliefs but the idea that that in fact
there's a lot of experience that we've
kind of consistent with the idea that
there's an immaterial soul like what
happens when you go to sleep and you
have a dream you know your body's been
in bed the whole time but it's very
natural to think that some other part of
you is up and about in the world
it's the screensaver it's like the
screensaver exact what do you what do
you say to the new metaphor which is my
mind is a computer well I think there's
something to be I not a computer in the
sense of product that you buy for at the
Apple store or from Adele but the idea
that they brain operates by the
processing of information by signals by
codes by transformations is I think an
essential insight into demystifying the
fact that this three-pound hunk of
matter can be intelligent that we could
do things like recognize faces speaking
grammatical sentences pick up a pencil
to really understand that you have to
think of the brain as processing
information computers do that too that
doesn't mean the brain is a computer any
more than the eye as a camera but in the
other hand the eye and the camera really
do work by some similar principles Joe
described you looted this before the
sponge divers are a great story in your
book about Greek archaeology and the
calculating machine that was discovered
on a ship on a shelf in the waters below
Greece
in telling that story you tell the story
of these sponge divers as kind of
archaeologists they're also you know
characters who have lived for thousands
of years in these very particular places
but they're also people who took
extraordinary risks at a time when
underwater diving became possible the
technology for exploring under the water
for long periods of time long periods of
time like an hour describe some of that
put us in dump us into the drink there
on that story this way the sponge divers
and okay so sponge divers in the
Mediterranean had been collecting
sponges for the same same way for
thousands of years diving down generally
naked you know free diving down their
breath yeah just holding their breath
grabbing the sponges coming back up they
were incredibly good at it whole sort of
islands worth of young men in the
Mediterranean would make their living
that way until somewhere around the
1860s somebody invented the the diving
suit they're kind of the big copper suit
with the you know the helmet and then
there's a tube that kind of runs up to a
boat on the surface above so you're
breathing compressed air from the boat
above so it seemed like this amazing
invention you know you can go down
deeper you can stay down for longer and
make more money by collecting more
sponges so it was introduced and kind of
spread across the island so there was a
nice story that the sponge divers were a
bit wary of this at first until the guy
who was kind of bringing the technology
and persuaded his pregnant wife to
demonstrate it she walked down in the
sea and after that there was no way that
they were not going to go for it they
were one macho yeah honey you do it
but they had no idea about the bends so
the fact that if you are breathing
compressed air at depth and they went
down you know really deep like 60 meters
or whatever you're going to suffer the
bends when you come back up and tens of
thousands of them died even more
paralyzed I mean I had no idea until I
started looking into this I was like why
did I not know this
and it just became this after a while
like rather than stopping it became this
kind of macho culture because I wasn't
really anything else for them to do so
it just became this kind of live fast
die young go out so yeah it's just well
I suppose one of those warning stories
about you know adopting new technology
before you really understand what's
what's happening so nothing to do with
the Antikythera mechanism but just one
of those stories that you kind of
uncover when you're looking into
something and you never realized you
were going to go down that route but it
yeah but it also had everything to do
with it in the sense that the sponge
divers embracing the technology says
something about medicine
the technology transforms the biology
beneath the sea because all the sponges
are harvested there's millions and
millions made from harvesting these
sponges until it's over harvested and
then the the job to be done is not just
sponge diving it's actually finding
archaeological you know objects
underneath the water and so that affects
archaeology which affects our
understanding of history and all of
these technologies kind of interact and
I have to say when I was reading about
the sponge divers I really thought that
would make a great novel some sponge
diver who kind of is an intersection of
all this because the common key is
science in all of it but what were you
guys talking about backstage when I had
to stay up here and you guys were all
just sort of talking to each other at
the table back there I just noticed what
a very chemistry was it about
who's got better dinner reservations
after because I actually think one of
the great things about this event
tonight if you would never have a piano
like you guys have heard together in the
same writing comparing those of us who
write from the beginning to the middle
to the end and those of us who can
sometimes start in media race and write
the last chapter first and then flesh
out the you know middle end who's
beginning middle end three beginning
middle of the scientists and the two of
you are middle and first that's a rather
personal question and the radio guy
writing a Thomas Monde the great
chairman now was to find a writer as a
person finds writing difficult and I can
tell you a story about that if you have
the patience to leave yes well why child
was in the first grade one of my
daughter's she came to me with a pad and
a pencil
and said I was absent yesterday and I'd
like you to write in an absence note for
the teacher so I was sitting at the
kitchen table and I started to write a
note and I said dear mrs. so and so
please forgive and then I thought why do
I have to ask her to forgive the child
she didn't commit a crime she'll a lousy
virus so I tore that page off and threw
it down and I started it again
my daughter Caroline and then I thought
of course she's my daughter and this
went on from Cyril to lose a pile of and
your daughter's freaking out the child
was crying the bus outside was blowing
and my wife said I can't believe this I
can't believe is the school let out so
then the moral of the story is writing
is difficult especially the short forms
Oh tell us another uncle Edgar you know
if I was on a radio show right now and
and had the the foolish impulse to ask
the question what is your mission as a
writer as most writers do they say I
don't have a mission I just do what I'm
doing but it seems to me that that
question is a little bit on the table
here in the sense that you have talked a
little bit about I want people to
understand the things that I find so
interesting and I really think it's part
of the people's sort of treasure that
they understand the kind of research
that you're permitted to do do you have
a mission Sean I would like to like
science which obviously affects the
world we live in this incredibly
dramatic way to be as much a part of the
everyday cultural conversation as
politics or sports or movies or
economics or art or literature you know
I think a lot of people write popular
level science books and they say well we
want to inspire people to become
scientists because that's how I got
inspired to become a scientist by
reading books oh just sit in my local
public library in the physics section
and read all those books and but that's
great but you know we have plenty of
scientists but I think that everybody
should be interested in science whether
or not they're professional scientists
Rob they should follow along they should
debate it every single person should
have their own favorite interpretation
of quantum mechanics that's what
now Joyce you've been writing since you
got a typewriter at age 14 I actually
even writing novels since you've got a
typewriter at age 14 I believe right so
I mean I hesitate to ask do you have a
mission when you start a book thinking
about your reading public well I think I
think we all want to communicate with
one another we are in a community and we
want to share our vision of our
perspective of the universe I suppose
and I feel that the writer bears witness
for people who are in some ways unable
to speak for themselves I do have a
certain vision maybe of social justice
and that seems to me maybe more primary
to mine writing than than dealing with
science but it's not exclusive you like
the short forms as well I mean you're
real you're real tweet twitter twitter
yeah
yes that's a whole new genre of writing
that's completely new and you're
scientifically speaking how does it work
for you
how does it work for 20 years 140
characters hundred forty characters well
it's a the extraction of a thought or a
preference or recommendation so you've
read a really interesting new book by
someone right here and you don't want to
read a whole article or a long book
review for the New York Review of Books
you know like 20,000 words you just have
140 characters and just recommend that
you send it out and within minutes I get
responses to that people say I'm going
to go out and buy that book or I've
always wanted to read that book and now
I'm going to read it so it's sort of
like a dialog with people all around the
country and Jack I didn't it was
Stephens book just recently people are
ready like within three minutes we're
saying I him I've had this book on my
list and now I'm going to go out and
read it
so that's kind of immediate response
that most most writers of literature
anyway don't get usually I mean yours
can go by before you hear from a reader
if there even is a reader
do you find it easy to get it into 140
characters though because I'm paralyzed
by that like how do you know well what
you would say it's not difficult it's
like saying you know how youhow do you
brush your teeth or something it's
actually not difficult but have you
tried it yeah I was on for a while but
when you were saying about the sick note
that's me on on Twitter I'd be there for
an hour like well that's not quite how I
want to say it and you know I'm a
freelancer nobody pays you for that so
I've had to stop no you could paid by
the character that would be a whole
different story than you do your whole
book in tweets so given your Jennifer
Egan did that to a novelist here in the
United States did she do it as a blog
was a tweet or a blog she did a novel
that was all in one of those social
media platforms but with your output
Joyce I suspect your frequency of tweets
would be on the nanosecond scale no
tweeting is something that I don't
consider integral to my life I could
very easily I mean I wasn't doing it
before a year or so ago I could just
stop it again where storytelling and
working with characters and setting
scenes and evoking some sort of
verisimilitude in the world that's very
rewarding and very exciting that's the
reason I read you know reading passage
as a Thomas Hardy or James Joyce you
know that the world is evoked in this
wonderfully vivid way to me that spirit
that's very exciting is there a mission
Edgar - to your work I get the sense
that on some level you want us to
experience American history in a very
personal tangible way well that was
never there was never part of my plan it
just sort
happen that some of these books were
said in the past but if you think about
it all novels are said in the past some
have a wider focus to include national
bandstand personages others a narrower
focus just about a family or a
relationship and then when I read
professor Carroll's book about time I
found a way to deny that I write
historical novels and he came up with a
theory called the eternalists theory of
time would you like to explain that I
would like it you explained it that'd be
great whoa this is a high-wire act now
when someone asks me that I just say I
write eternalists novels that's what I
did but really I'm trying to in terms of
this discussion I was trying to think
about that what interests me about
Sciences is the philosophical issue
involved in the whole scientific
research for instance as to the brain
why did I make of a character in the in
Andrews brain a cognitive scientist
because I wanted
someone to speak with authority about
self estrangement and he says it at a
certain point how can I think about my
brain if it's my brain doing with
thinking and you see the dissociation
right there which explains the miserable
life he's had and then I realized that
this is a battle that's going on today
between me between the neuroscientists
and the philosophers of mind this is a
this is a battle and it's of great
consequence because if it turns out that
neurosciences can someday replicate the
brain in a computer and there are some
people I think in Switzerland who would
try to do that now and even though it
may billions of billions of connections
are involved their position is that the
brain is finite and medical how these
Swiss brains are fine
right they do eat a lot of chocolate
there that's true but when that happens
presumably when we can replicate the
brain it will have consciousness and at
that point all the old stories we've
been telling ourselves since the Bronze
Age are finished there the idea of what
it means to be human
is transformed I don't really understand
like that is that not just ignoring the
fact that you need a body that
consciousness is embodied that the the
you know the the molecules coursing
around in our bloodstream affect how we
feel affect our emotions so I mean maybe
important to talk about that so I don't
understand this idea that you can just
take the brain away and have it on its
own and somehow you're going to have
something like a human right well
there's it's actually not completely
clear whether the actual subjective
experience of being alive and awake you
know and and aware and seeing read and
hearing middle C and tasting sour and so
on depends on being made of human flesh
that is whether you want to be a meat
feminist about consciousness or whether
it's a question of processing patterns
of information so that a suitably
configured robot or Android could be
considered to depend on the physical
state of our body you know just ranking
the brain through through neurons and so
in this science fiction scenario in
which the you have an artificial brain
that would include inputs from signals
that would replicate the sensation of
you know fingertips and your drums and
retinas and so on or other kinds of
inputs or other kinds of no sort of body
analog doesn't have to be easier and
people have been struggling to make
artificial intelligence for a long time
and one of the hot topics in artificial
intelligence these days is putting it
inside a robot and you put your attempt
at a earning intelligent program and
give it a body and give it a face and
they are very quickly much better than
any of the purely software attempts at
making something that seems alive and
this actually has been played out in
fiction as many themes in philosophy of
science and philosophy of mind have been
often in science fiction I mean in
popular pop science-fiction there is an
episode of Star Trek the next generation
in which they have to decide whether it
would be ethical to dismantle Lieutenant
Commander data to reverse engineer him
whether this would be disassembling a
machine or tantamount to murder and you
know how do you know you ask him are you
conscious that he says yes oh yeah but
it's been programmed to say yes is there
really someone home in there who's
actually feeling something or is it just
a bunch of programming but then you know
how do I know that you're not just a
bunch of programming that's been wired
up to save your conscious so these are
philosophical issues that have been
played out in fiction can I ask the
question of the scientist here so much
of our lives are genetically determined
we've inherited things you know when we
were born so how what is the analog with
artificial intelligence there's no
genetic code that generates artificial
intelligence this is the specification
where would that come from let's say
well intelligent any intelligent system
would have to learn but it would have to
be equipped with algorithms for learning
or mechanisms that take in inputs and
change as a result and the equivalent to
nature I would say would be in the
nature nurture transferred to human-made
systems would be the learning algorithms
that you program into the system would
be like the nature and then
the way it actually processes
information and changes as a result
would be the equivalent of nurture what
point would it become autonomous though
you're programming something that's very
complex but you're you're programming it
there's a some point we're just going to
say I'm on my own or something that's
the part where we find hard to
comprehend it certainly could be
possible with Arif to just to continue
the analogy natural selection would be
the process that gave rise to the
complexity of the human brain or the
brains of other animals that go ahead
and do learning this in this case it
would be duplicated by a human engineer
in the same way that a lot of natural
systems like you know like like wood and
like plants could be replicated by human
engineers and of course natural Darwin's
great insight was that natural selection
simulated an engineer without there
actually being any engineering very slow
but very slow yeah so engineers work
slowly to taking your point though and
going back to something that you said
Joe is it and and referencing something
that you said also choice I mean is it
possible to even conceive of an
artificial intelligence autonomous
entity without its connection to the
Creator so if there was a DNA genetic
code for artificial intelligence it
would have to begin with the human
creators who actually it's impossible to
imagine it in the abstract right it's
got to be connected to the human
creators well the human creator could
have designed it but then once design it
goes
fumbling off by itself seeking energy
sources using its own internal
information processing to try to attain
goals in other words it's a fancy way of
saying
there's nothing that makes it impossible
to build a robot it's very very
difficult to build a robot that can
duplicate what a human could do but
presumably there's no barrier in
principle and then the question is would
it actually be conscious in the sense of
there being someone home feeling someone
something well that's the what's
sometimes called the so-called hard
problem of consciousness we mentioned
John Cyril you mentioned I haven't
mentioned philosopher mind who did an
experiment to show a computer seeming to
demonstrate intelligence and doing all
the right things without having any idea
of what it was doing so the whole idea
of artificial intelligence doesn't
suggest necessarily consciousness that's
so there's idea that that Searles idea
yeah yeah Cyril actually would argue
that artificial intelligence well that
that just implementing rules the way a
computer does because there is no
consciousness that shows that
consciousness does depend on having a
beam actually made out of flesh and
having a having a brain that if it was
just rules then you could imagine
someone a person in a room implementing
a very very very complicated set of
rules for translating a Chinese but he
still would not understand a word of
Chinese ergo following a bunch of rules
and understanding Chinese according to
Searles argument or not the same thing
and conferring Stars babies Turing's
argument would be if you can fool
somebody with consciousness then that is
a threshold that's important in some way
I took a very depressing quiz on the
internet recently it was they had 20
poems ten of them had been written by
human beings and ten of them had been
artificially intelligently generated and
usually I'm really good at this but it
was like 5050 I could not tell which
poems have been written by human beings
now they didn't pick sonnets right they
picked more sort of modernist
experimental thing
but I think that the what we're working
toward in the field is an idea that
consciousness is not so much a threshold
that there are matters of degrees no one
thinks that those computer programs who
wrote these poems are consciousness or
artistic or conscious or artistic or
literary anyway but that's because they
like a whole bunch of other things that
we associate with consciousness and it
might be that there's just completely
different ways to be conscious and when
we do get artificial intelligence
it'll be consciousness in a way that is
practically it'll be conscious in a way
that is practically unrecognizable as
human well even in our own experience
there are so many different kind ways to
be conscious something you know in a 24
hour period we'll go through that
sometimes six of them you know a lot of
writers are referred to as having sort
of scientific attributes in some way I'm
interested do you think Dostoyevsky
who's described often as a very
psychological a kind of inner
consciousness sort of writer it would be
a good psychiatrist I suspect he I
suspect he would he was certainly a very
psychological writer and I anticipated
Freud's unconscious his characters
wrestle with the very dilemma that I
mentioned in response to your first
question mainly how do we reconcile our
common sense view of consciousness as
involving something immaterial with the
discovery of science that it's just a
bunch of neurons and in the Brothers
Karamazov he has Alyosha and his brother
actually pondering this imponderable
with just wiggling little tails of cells
in our in our head and that's all of my
experience and they were grappling with
that very dilemma I suspect what Whitman
Edgar would be a terrific astronaut I am
a fellow who wonders why astronomers
don't run screaming from their
telescopes
so the answer is I would not make a good
astronaut okay
well but Whitman had a curiosity and a
sense of adventure about the future and
it seemed like he would want to sign up
to go to the moon if he were alive and
uh do I get to take a pen and pen
shortly I mean I think he would probably
come up with something slightly more
inventive than one small step for man
one giant I'm quite serious in wondering
why cosmologists don't go crazy why why
they treat it as a as an adventure and
as an intellectual game when it's really
quite hideous to contemplate I don't
understand why everyone except for
cosmologists doesn't go
you know the universe is out there we
live I think what the implicit question
here is we live in this absolutely
bizarre challenging difficult to
understand universe and I'm privileged
enough to like get paid as my full-time
job to think about what it all means and
what it does and so forth and yeah I
feel bad for people who don't get that
privilege because you terrified about
the different terrifies me the
differences scientists are always very
hopeful for instance Einstein no matter
what the difficulties were he he had
this scientific idea that eventually
things could be figured out but
Wittgenstein the German philosopher
Austrian philosopher said no matter how
many of the scientific questions we'll
managed to answer in fact all of them we
will still not have gotten touched the
problem so that's that's the difference
between the scientific optimism and sort
of philosophical despair would you say
that Vic and Stein discovered dark
matter
in a big way
could have been Kierkegaard although he
was less dark I think you've just
insulted the ghost I think so well we've
come to the end I as always in these
sessions get completely lost and lose
track of time completely we've come to
the end I want to thank Sean and Edgar
and Joe and Joyce and Steven thank you
so much